brasil sigue al borde del colapso a
causa del cobi 19 el gran repunte de
contagios hizo que la agencia nacional
de vigilancia sanitaria la máxima
autoridad sanitaria del país decidiera
prevenir un posible desabastecimiento de
oxígeno y medicamentos para los
pacientes más graves tras superar por
quinto día consecutivo las 2400 muertes
la gente anunció una serie de medidas de
urgencia temporales permitiendo el uso
de los cilindros de gas natural para gas
medicinal la importación de medicamentos
prohibidos en el país la eliminación de
las prácticas burocráticas en la
distribución de fármacos usados en las
ucis y el cambio en el proceso de
verificación de los fármacos con buena
parte de su sistema sanitario colapsado
el país sudamericano vive su peor
momento desde el inicio de la pandemia
las entidades sanitarias de varias
ciudades y avisaron que están al límite
río de janeiro tiene una ocupación del
95 por ciento de sus camas en terapia
intensiva situación que obligó al cierre
de sus icónicas playas este fin de
semana por él
ciudades como puerto alegre y sao paulo
la más golpeada por la pandemia y
avisaron de problemas en el suministro
de oxígeno en sao paulo una decena de
pacientes tuvieron que ser trasladados
de urgencia a otro hospital por falta de
insumos y en portoalegre al menos seis
personas murieron por la misma razón las
autoridades sanitarias temen una
situación similar a la crisis de falta
de oxígeno en el estado del amazonas' el
pasado enero un desabastecimiento que se
cobró la vida de al menos 50 pacientes